you did a lot of training before you
even started filming tell me a little
bit about what that involved it involved
stunt fighting horse riding we learned
to fight like dwarves we learn to ride
horses like dwarves we learned to
communicate as dwarves we learn to walk
like dwarves and talk like dwarves and
we was hilarious actually I just tell
you a funny story we did a lot of
working on the movement of dwarves and
also working together as a as a team and
so one day we did that but we went
outside of the building where we were
we're training in and we did it outside
in a park area and it was in a public
area to the footpath so you got 14 grown
men sneaking through the trees acting
like I don't know what the public must
have thought because people looking at
us would have thought what are those
guys doing no we're sneaking around
through the trees were pretending to
like campfires and pretending we're
being chased by orcs and gosh it was
really really funny yeah we did we did a
huge amount of training for it did you
think when you were sneaking around at
that point my God we're gonna get
arrested in a minute I did actually sort
of think if they make you know somebody
might the police might arrive or the me
even worse the media but what most
importantly it was like a chance for us
to kind of to get to know each other and
work together as a group and yeah we did
that for two and a half nearly three
months before we even started rolling
the camera I know I know they would
introduce bit by bit like that would
introduce our weapons so we learn to
fight with our particular weapons it
would introduce the pieces of costume
the funny thing is we spent so much time
actually learning to kind of walk with a
much heavier kind of base thus wolves
are quite are very earth as people and
so we had to kind of walk with cherry
notary is a fantastic movement coach
would teach us they had to walk like we
had a cannonball on our stomach like
really low and down so we spent months
doing that and then one day they brought
in the boots that we had to wear and the
boots are
huge and the boots did all the work
twerk all that work for you anyway so we
didn't actually really need to do it all
but don't tell them because you know it
was still fun are you invention weapons
there you got quite attached to one of
your weapons didn't you literally
attached how is it having that acts on
your head that well I that was a that
was an amazing moment actually when we
first saw our the depictions of our
characters you know and we it was an
amazing day we were all sitting together
and they've had portraits of each
character that they were bringing out
and we were just going oh my god because
are also incredible and then mine came
out and I had the axe on my head and for
about a second I thought that's weird
and then I thought that's fantastic
because it gives me as an actor a whole
lot of things to work with so we ended
up introducing a whole lot of things
into two buffers character to do with
the acts like he's zoned out and I did a
whole lot of research on the effect of
something like that that kind of injury
might have and from that came the idea
that I'd speak in cuz duel like it's
like almost like a foreign language
syndrome so it was it gave me a whole
lot of things to hook around as an actor
and it's an orc X so there's a history
I've been through some terrible stuff
and so I my backstory that you know we'd
all create sort of stories for ourselves
my backstory is that you know my family
was in a terrible terrible fight
attacked by orcs and I lost a whole lot
of people and you know it's a bit of a
sad character but as the film goes on
but if it kind of finds himself a bit
now you mentioned as well the foreign
language syndrome there of course you
talking to the dwarvish don't you how
did you find doing now that stuff to
learn well we have dialogue coaches all
the time there so it was tough to learn
but because funny thing is that they
actually are very very strict about
doing it right even though it's actually
a protein language stop all that on see
it all the time would ever dialogue
coach and if you seen anything wrong
they come all you know can't you gotta
do it right you know you say oh no it's
made up
not real yes so anyway yeah cause bell
cool you know you'd have to say that
means mighty dwarf it's a secret
language though so don't tell the other
dwarves because they'll kill me if I go
around speaking it course you work quite
closely with andy serkis you also worked
quite closely with stephen hunter and
also james nesbitt as well didn't you
what was it like working with those guys
I will listen we were like a brotherhood
we were like a family and when you go
through so many different experiences
together with a group of people you do
form a very special bond you know and so
like when we came back when we came back
to filming this year we've been away or
look at eight months maybe even more cut
10 months we'd actually stopped filming
last year and then we came back to do
another block which we finished about
three months ago but the day we came
back it was just like nothing you know
like it was just like an overnight thing
like that 10 months just disappeared
like that and it was just like being
back in the fold and the Family fold you
know our trailers weren't exactly the
same place the makeup bus was in exactly
the same place all the same people were
there it was like Groundhog Day it was
hilarious ya know we did we formed a
bond and what else you know because we
just had so many adventures together
it's funny because the adventures that
we had together as a group of actors are
just like the adventures that the
characters and the movie have together
they go on this journey because we did
all the stuff a real you know all the
barrels stuff where you have to see the
next film actually I can't tell you
about the next film but you've the
trailers already out so yea though
riding in the barrels it was an
incredible experience your course if you
mentioned that we just seen the trailer
for the next row on desolation so what
do you think fans can look forward to
most from that second part of the
trilogy all I know is from the little
bits i have seen it looks like it is it
ramps everything up to another level and
peter jackson is a genius and all i can
say because people keep asking me they
say oh what's it going to be what I
think it is
going to be amazing I'm looking forward
to seeing how it all unfolds and the
story unfolds I'm looking forward to
seeing all our work on the screen and
see how what they do with it you know
and you mentioned Peter Jackson of
course there what would you like to work
with its first time you work with him
wasn't it on the first film he is a at
the heart of it peter is a an artist and
he is a creative person what's wonderful
about working with somebody like Peter
Jackson is it he he brings it ensemble
cast together like but he is like it
it's the talent of the man is incredible
but really it's not the fact that he is
it's really the fact that he is a
creative personality and then that's the
most exciting thing and it draws people
to get that kind of personality draws
thing people together happen and Lord of
the Rings they formed a special bond it
happened to us we formed a special bond
and it's because he is a very very
talented artist finally what was it like
was one of the guys who is based over in
that part of the world filming there and
then welcoming a cast of all parts the
world over as well well what was great
is discovering the hour your own country
and rediscovering pieces because we went
to places that were just incredibly
beautiful places and you know and then
we did stuff like really got into
barrels in a real River and we just had
so many adventures but it was as very
exciting to actually feel proud of your
own country like that and the way it's
depicted on the screen it really is
middle-earth you know our version of
middle-earth it's New Zealand really but
you know it is middle-earth for all
intents and purposes but anyway yeah so
bring it on it's going to be an exciting
ride and I just hope people to just go
and see the film and enjoy it for what
it is thanks so much you're talking to
swim really appreciate I hey thank you
for having me i'm really loving it here
it's great lovely people thank you
you